und wir sprechen über Post Wut in
Deutschland tagelang keine Briefe nichts
im Briefkasten tausende zehntausende
Beschwerden die bei der Deutschen Post
eingehen quer durch Deutschland und die
Post sagt na ja stimmt ja alles aber bei
uns haben halt gerade so viele Corona
tja aber deshalb wochenlang keine Briefe
nur weil da auch eben Corona
ausgebrochen ist Bild macht das zum
großen Diskussionsthema hier in
Deutschland was ist bitte los bei der
Deutschen Post
Wut wegen der Deutschen Post tagelang
kommt keine Briefe die Zustellung
verzögert oder gar nicht Frust bei den
Empfängern weil Briefe plötzlich einfach
im Fahrstuhlschacht gefunden werden oder
gar im Müll es nervt mich sehr dass die
Post nicht mehr verlässlich ist sie
kommt wann sie will wenn ich
Zeitschriften bestelle dann kommen die
nicht an dem Tag wo sie eigentlich immer
am Stand zu kaufen geht sondern manchmal
Tage später oder auch gar nicht so die
Briefe kommen auch nicht mehr jeden Tag
an also zwei drei mal die Woche
höchstens und ansonsten ist der
Postkasten definitiv leer ich habe
festgestellt dass in letzter Zeit die
Post nicht mehr regelmäßig ausgetragen
wird das postchaos wird immer schlimmer
aber was ist los warum kommt die Post
nicht mehr bereits
20.421 Beschwerden registrierte die
Bundesnetzagentur in Bonn bisher für
2022 ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht
pressesprecherin
im ersten Halbjahr gab es
14.760 Beschwerde Gründe davon entfielen
46% auf den Brief und 35% auf das Paket
meistens ging es um zustellausfall und
mangelhafte Zustellung doch jetzt
steigen die Beschwerden sogar noch mehr
also ein Brief vor der tiert auf dem 20
September und ich habe ihn bekommen 11
oktober also oder 12 Oktober aktuell
habe ich auf einen Brief gewartet der am
19.8 verschickt wurde von der
Krankenkasse das waren sehr wichtiger
Brief für mich weil ich derzeit
krankgeschrieben bin und diverse
Untersuchungen habe und dieser Brief
wurde mir am 16.09 erst zugestellt
die Deutsche Post DHL Group weiß von den
zustellschwierigkeiten der Grund
offenbar hoher Krankheitsstand wegen
Corona und Personalmangel eine schnelle
Lösung für das postproblem leider nicht
zustellbar tja keine Post kein gar nix
keine Rechnung aber was bedeutet das
eigentlich darüber wollen wir mal
sprechen mit unserem sparvort Frank
Ochse schönen guten Morgen Frank also
was mache ich denn eigentlich wenn meine
Post verspätet ist ich aber eigentlich
irgendwelche Fristen einzuhalten hatte
wer haftet denn in so einer Geschichte
ja bitterer Weise muss man sagen wir
Kunden sind da wieder mal die dummen
weil letztlich die Post lehnt jegliche
Schadensersatzansprüche bei normalen
Briefen ab das heißt also muss jetzt
genau gucken worum es geht verpasse ich
irgendwie Fristen sagt die Post auch nee
ist nicht unser Ding letztlich wir äh
ist dieser Brief hatte jetzt keine
Sendungsverfolgung war halt kein
Einschreiben insofern rate ich
tatsächlich klar die Rechnung müssen
bezahlt werden auch Strafzettel Pipapo
aber ganz wichtig ich der
rechnungsversender sollte dann zumindest
die Mahngebühren erlassen und natürlich
wissen dass auch die Versender das ist
vielleicht in Berlin oder in einigen
bayerischen oder süddeutschen Gemeinden
da Probleme gibt ich glaube da lässt man
sich drauf ein also tatsächlich wenn die
Briefe zu spät kommen bloß keinem Anzahl
die merke ich überhaupt dass ein Brief
nicht kommt ich weiß doch gar nicht dass
er kommt ja grundsätzlich muss man sagen
von einer Forderung die ich nicht im
Briefkasten habe die muss ich natürlich
auch nicht bezahlen aber natürlich
machen das die rechnungsversender so
dass sie natürlich dann eine
Zahlungserinnerung schreiben vielleicht
auch die erste Mahnung das heißt es
bleibt ja nicht bei einem Brief und dann
passiert nichts also insofern ist es
dann schon möglich dass irgendwie diese
Forderung an mich herangetragen wird ja
aber wenn der erste Brief den ich dann
tatsächlich wieder bekomme dann schon
der vom Inkassounternehmen ist was mache
ich dann auch hier gilt natürlich immer
wirklich auf die auf die Fristen achten
und natürlich ganz klar sagen ich habe
hier seit Wochen keine Post bekommen
davon ist offenbar auch dieser Brief
betroffen das heißt ich bitte jetzt um
Fristverlängerung und Zahlen natürlich
die richtige Gebühren nicht die Post
sagt halt ist nicht unser Ding und
verweisen da drauf dass nur wenn
letztlich ein klarer Zustelltermin
vereinbart worden ist das ist halt bei
diesem teuren Express Sendung ab 11 €
das zahlt natürlich keiner erst dann
sagt die Post na gut das ist dann schon
unser Ding aber selbst zum Beispiel bei
Einschreiben erstattet die Post maximal
beim berühmten Einwurf Einschreiben 20
Euro 6 Wochen keine Briefe sechs Wochen
nichts im Briefkasten ist ja schon krass
und das haben ganz viele im Moment in
Deutschland erlebt er sagt die Deutsche
Post irgendwie von dieser Missstand
behoben ist also wann mal wieder ein
Brief eingeworfen wird ja die Deutsche
Post äh rekrutiert jetzt neue
Mitarbeiter ich dachte zum Beispiel auch
jetzt ein ein Zusteller der ist ja in
der frischen Luft da kann man sich gar
nicht so infizieren aber tatsächlich
sitzen natürlich morgens zusammen und
sortieren Ihre Post und packen das alles
ein und dort kommt es dann zu diesem
corona-infektionen die Deutsche Post
rekrutiert jetzt neue Mitarbeiter aber
ehrlicherweise sind die halt fürs
Weihnachtsgeschäft geplant also insofern
eine besserung ist nicht in Sicht naja
vielleicht klappt es ja dann wenigstens
mit den Weihnachtsgeschenken wollen wir
Dankeschön Franks
[Musik]